finies les vacances de printemps finies
les vacances pour le printemps il est
enfin là aucune nouvelle d'aldo moro
l'intervention de pulse is accentue le
malaise politique en italie
les remous au sein du pc pour la
première fois la télévision
d'intellectuels communiste jean et
weinstein explique pourquoi il compte s
de la ligne officielle
le tiercé de longchamp dans l'ordre le
11 le 13 et le 16
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
personnes autour du circuit du mans pour
assister à la victoire de l'élan et
chmakh 1 cet après midi sur une honda
d'usiné et puis des dizaines des
centaines de milliers de français dans
les parcs à la campagne dans les jardins
ou pour les plus chanceux ceux qui
habitent au bord de la mer sur les
plages la france a connu aujourd'hui sa
première vraie journée de printemps il a
fait beau partout il a fait chaud et
cela devrait dit-on commis continuer
demain dans la capitale
parisiens et touristes provinciaux ou
étrangers se sont retrouvés tout au long
de cette journée à la terrasse des cafés
sur les champs elysées ou bien au champ
de mars
on n'a pas encore vu deux jeunes femmes
commençaient à bronzer sur les berges de
la seine mais cela ne devrait plus
tarder maintenant en italie
c'est un nouveau à nouveau un week end
attentes que l'on a connues aujourd'hui
dans la sphère aldo moro ce matin le
pape paul 6 s'est adressé à la foule des
fidèles qui s'étaient massés sur la
place saint-pierre à rome
la tante nous permet d'espérer a déclaré
paul 6 les brigades rouges cependant
garde toujours le silence
elles n'ont répondu ni à l'appel du pape
ni à monsieur courte valdan ni à
l'organisation internationale
caritas la lettre du pape réclamant à
genoux la libération d'aldo moro a été
reproduite dans tous les journaux
d'italie l'appel du souverain pontife
est devenue une lueur d'espoir est même
l'un des avocats des brigadistes
considère que l'imploration et
d'importance dans un pays où les
crucifix se retrouve jusque dans les
commissariats de police
la prise de position du vatican est le
dernier recours devant saint pierre de
rome ce matin la foule plus nombreuse
qu'à l'accoutumée attendait de la bouche
même du pape
l'appel aux brigades rouges
dimanche
au sein de l'église
la prise de position du pape n'a pas
surpris samedi à peu près qu'il espérait
que le crime qui risque d'être commis
sera épargné aaron à l'italie au monde
et à la famille du de monsieur moreau je
crois que dans le contexte actuel
de la situation politique en italie
c'est un acte très courageux mais on
on peut saluer pense cet acte est un
père on espère ici en italie que les
hommes des brigades rouges comme les
appelait le pape entendront enrico
berlinguer le communiste a apprécié
l'appel de paul 6 pour une libération
sans condition et sans dictats
terroristes il faudrait maintenant que
tout cela ne reste pas lettre morte
le réponse hier a les yeux fixés en ce
moment sur l'italie si vous le savez
dans la sphère de brigades rouges la
police italienne coopère avec les
services policiers des autres pays du
marché commun et notamment les services
policiers de l'allemagne une coopération
qui se fait sans bruit et dont on ne
connaît pas encore les résultats
mais symbole tout de même en dépit des
difficultés que connaît le marché commun
de la solidarité européenne
demain pour l'europe c'est d'une autre
solidarité dont il sera question celle
là ne touche plus le coeur mais le porte
monnaie les neuf ministres de
l'agriculture se réunissent à luxembourg
une nouvelle fois on va donc parler des
prix et donc du revenu des agriculteurs
mais avant d'aborder cette négociation
deux pays la france et l'italie se sont
mis d'accord pour que l'on discute en
priorité des problèmes de l'agriculture
méditerranéenne une obligation pour les
agriculteurs français
ils vont devoir s'adapter avant que la
grèce le portugal et l'espagne
n'entre dans le marché comme la vigne
principale composante de l'agriculture
méditerranéenne depuis longtemps discuté
ici dans le midi de la france
la commission agricole européenne
propose deux solutions pour remédier aux
excédents et à la mauvaise qualité du
vin la première restructurer le vignoble
en y apportant des cépages de meilleure
qualité
la deuxième la reconversion je crois pas
qu'on puisse convertir notre vignoble
pour faire autre chose car les
structures le climat ne ne correspond
pas à ce genre de 2,2 de reconversion et
on sait pas quoi
pourtant il ya une autre manière de
reconversion ici par an il est possible
de faire des moutons il est possible de
faire de la vente il est possible de
faire beaucoup de choses ici oui il est
possible de faire de la lavande mais
tout ça est quand même assez limité et
ceux qui en font jusqu'à maintenant
c'est des surfaces tout à fait minime et
le marché serait vite saturé si toutes
les vignes devait s'arracher pour faire
de la lame
vous parlez d auvergne on est un pays à
enfin il ya eu des vagues et les
troupeaux diminue
chaque année car la concurrence avec
l'angleterre dans le marché commun et
ses importations de vins de la nouvelle
zélande risque de compromettre encore
plus gravement que simon fusion du duvet
touchés par les gelées de 1956 et 1963
andré pagnol lui a préféré ajouter une
corde à son arc
en élevant des chaises mais aujourd'hui
le contexte économique est différent et
ne conseillerais pas un autre
viticulteur de se reconvertir
parce qu'il est difficile de conseiller
parce que s'il y a beaucoup de chèvre
beaucoup de pommiers où entre autres
cultures le problème à se poser sur le
plan de la commercialisation
parce qu'il y aura des excédents c'est
certain vous vous avez gardé de la vigne
c'est notre principale activité je n'ai
pas l'intention de lâcher bien et les
autres composantes de l'agriculture
méditerranéenne les fruits et légumes
la principale crainte des producteurs se
situe dans la concurrence que
provoquerait l'entrée dans le marché
commun de la grèce du portugal et de
l'espagne
on s'adapte à une concurrence dont les
coûts de production que sont le quart de
celle de de cette région pour visiter
ces personnes courent est ici gagne 4
fois plus que dans leur pays d'origine
qu'elle portugal ne sais pas dans
combien de temps vous pensé justement
l'entrée parham de l'espagne ont voulu
tard de mieux le plus tard cela le mieux
l'espoir en tout état de cause
en tout les congés difficile de fixer un
délai nous produire 10 12 15 jan mais il
faudra à ce moment-là voir où en sont
ces pays-là par rapport à l'évolution
mais déjà la concurrence italienne est
présente surtout en ce qui concerne les
légumes dans ce domaine les producteurs
français envient les aides apportées par
l'europe à leur concurrent italien le
mezzogiorno a je crois prévu de 5000
hectares qui vont voir le jour sous
forme d'hectares irrigués qui vont
produire des fruits et légumes et qui
vont venir élèves inéluctablement sur le
marché
l'europe et ses deux cent mille hectares
sont subventionnés par la communauté
européenne à 3 200 mille hectares qui
vont recevoir par ailleurs de l'ordre de
280 à 300 techniciens qui seront
financés à 80% par la communauté
européenne
mais c'est pas le cas en france et ce
n'est pas du tout le cas en france en
particulier notre région et nous
aimerions effectivement dans une région
aride comme la nôtre si l'eau abonde
certains points comme ici par exemple il
ya des coins qui cette certaines petites
régions de notre ou six ans qui manquent
cruellement d'eau finalement en abordant
le dossier méditerranéen luxembourg les
neuf ministres de l'agriculture du
marché commun ont encore une fois de
plus buté sur des négociations longues
et difficiles congrès du parti
socialiste à la fin de la semaine comité
central du parti communiste
au milieu de cette semaine deux réunions
qui auront lieu à huis clos mais qui
l'une comme l'autre revêt une très
grande importance chez les socialistes
comme chez les communistes
il s'agira de dresser le bilan des
élections des 12 et 19 mars
et aussi de faire le bilan de ce qui
s'est passé ensuite abandon du programme
commun contestation au sein du parti
communiste
du côté de la majorité conséquences
aussi de ces élections monsieur jean
lecanuet qui préside aujourd'hui le
conseil politique du mouvement des
démocrates sociaux a décidé de ne plus
être désormais le porte-parole de ce
mouvement
cet après midi monsieur jean lecanuet
s'en est d'ailleurs expliqué il m'est
apparu qu'il n'était pas possible d'être
à la fois le porte parole des l'udf et
celui de la formation politique à
laquelle je continue d'appartenir et que
je continuerai de présider cette
présidence me permettra de vivre à
l'intérieur des instances dirigeantes du
cds et par conséquent de contribuer
ainsi pour ma part à l'harmonie de
l'action du cds et de l'union pour la
démocratie française
mais à l'avenir ce sont les autres
dirigeants du
sc je le répète tout particulièrement
bernard stasi qui aura la charge
d'entretenir la communication entre le
cds et l'opinion publique et par
conséquent de vous rencontrer et de
s'exprimer dans leur s ibarruri réélue
présidente santiago carillo réélu
secrétaire général en apparence le 9e
congrès du parti communiste espagnol le
premier qui se soit tenu officiellement
au grand jour depuis plus de 40 ans ne
laisse apparaître aucun changement mais
en apparence seulement car le parti de
monsieur santiago carillo en trois jours
a fait un grand pas vers ce que l'on a
commune que l'on appelle communément
l'eurocommunisme moscou ne s'est dit
elle ne s'y est d'ailleurs pas trompé
excusez-moi la pravda ce matin condamné
cette évolution qui fait le jeu de la
bourgeoisie et du capitalisme cet après
midi près de trente mille personnes ont
participé au meeting de clôture de ce
congrès une phrase surtout a été
applaudie dans le discours de monsieur
santiago carillo celle où le secrétaire
général a affirmé que le parti
communiste espagnol aurait un jour la
force parlementaire suffisante pour
réclamer sa participation au pouvoir
ce premier congrès du parti communiste
espagnol célébrée dans la légalité était
en fête le congrès de laurent communisme
et après l'extraordinaire meeting
organisé ce matin dans les arènes de
carabanchel
il a faim du congrès hier on peut dire
que ce congrès se solde par un succès
incontestable pour le secrétaire général
santiago carillo cela ne doit pas faire
oublier non plus que ce succès a été
acquis qu'à l'issue de discussions
souvent très tendu et qui ont fait
grincer l'appareil du parti communiste
espagnol
certes la ligne cariste l'a emporté
litaize euros communiste figure
désormais noir sur blanc dans les
statuts du parti
l'abandon du terme léninisme cette mise
à jour voulu par santi avocat rayon est
acquis
les opposants se sont exprimés
démocratiquement c'est vrai mais à
permettre à leurs au communisme de
franchir un nouveau pas le pce se heurte
une nouvelle fois à moscou pour qui la
doctrine sûrs aux communistes n'existe
pas d'après nous leur communisme
n'existe pas parce qu'il n'y a qu'un
seul communisme le communisme
scientifique marxiste léniniste qui se
mettent en pratique en fonction des
conditions concrètes de chaque pays
celle de l'italie ou de la france par
exemple l'histoire confirme que seul le
marxisme-léninisme a permis de
construire le socialisme et par
conséquent nous considérons que d'euros
communisme n'existe pas et nous ne
pouvons pas accepter thunder de ce
congrès les observateurs ont aussi
retenu l'absence des deux autres leaders
européens qui il y a à peine plus d'un
an avait signé à madrid avec santiago
carillo
le premier document euros communiste
georges marchais et enrick obert lingway
de là à en déduire que l'esprit de ce
sommet s'était effacée il n'y avait
qu'un afin que l'on ne peut pas franchir
car en évoluant ainsi le parti de
monsieur santiago carillo tente de
rattraper son retard sur le parti
communiste italien est aussi sur le
parti communiste français et de l'autre
côté des pyrénées comme chez nous bruno
alba nous le rappelait cette évolution
ne se fait pas sans contestation alors
pour la première fois depuis les
élections pour la première fois aussi
depuis qu'un débat s'est ouvert au sein
du parti communiste français
l'historien du parti communiste monsieur
jean hélène stein a accepté de répondre
aux questions que nous voulions lui
poser sur l'évolution des différents
partis communistes européens alors en
abandonnant la référence aux léninisme
dans sa fille ni définition le parti
communiste
espagnole est il encore à parti
communiste écoutez la réponse de
monsieur joe reinstein bien entendu non
seulement il est encore un parti
communiste mais je dirais que bien des
égards il l'est plus encore aujourd'hui
qu'il ne l'était hier dans la mesure où
il a amélioré ses règles de
fonctionnement donnant plus de
démocratie à l'intérieur du parti
en rénovant un certain nombre de
structures et en posant de plein fouet
les problèmes centraux qui sont ceux des
sociétés occidentales
on parle beaucoup d'euros communisme est
ce que ce n'est pas une formule un peu
vide encore coûté l'eurocommunisme c'est
une formule comme vous le dites et
forcément toute formule qui n'a pas reçu
le baptême du feu de l'histoire reste
une formule je crois que derrière le mot
communisme il y à une nouvelle
définition des rapports entre la liberté
la démocratie il socialisme et c'est ce
que le congrès du parti communiste
espagnol a exprimé de façon tout à fait
clair les communistes espagnols se vend
aujourd'hui d'avoir surmonté le
stalinisme
est-ce que lui recettes encore
stalinienne écoutez je crois qu'il faut
d'abord bien s'entendre sur la
définition du mou stalinien staline est
mort depuis 20 ans et je crois que
beaucoup plus que de stalinisme il faut
surtout parler d'une certaine
pratique de l'état qui a abouti aux
formes monstrueuses que l'on appelle le
stalinisme et qu'en réalité à travers la
situation actuelle de lurs les
institutions qui ont donné naissance au
stalinisme le parti unique l'absence
totale de démocratie politique
subsistent et que par conséquent les
racines profondes du stalinisme existent
encore entre le communiste santiago
carillo le communiste leonid brejnev y
at il un point commun ils y a évidemment
des points communs mais je dirais qu'il
y a de plus en plus des différences
extrêmement importante fondamentale
puisqu'elle touche précisément à la
conception même du socialisme rapport
entre la démocratie et le socialisme
vous avez dit d'ailleurs que lui recette
est pour vous un anti-modèle qu'entendez
vous par là
bien je veux dire par là qu'elle n'est
ni un modèle ni une expérience que nous
ne savons pas vraiment ce que peut être
le socialisme puisqu'il n'existe nulle
part tel que nous le concevons en france
tels que le 22ème congrès du parti
communiste français l'a défini mais que
nous savons en tout cas de façon
certaine ce qui ne doit pas être est ce
qu'il ne doit pas être c'est précisément
ce système où il n'y a pas de démocratie
politique et où la bureaucratie d'hommes
de mines tel qu'il fonctionne avec les
parties et à en union soviétique où dans
un certain nombre de pays de sault tiff
diriez vous comme les espagnols que le
parti communiste français a lui aussi su
remonter le stalinisme côté on peut
toujours le dire et je crois que
théoriquement cela est vrai le parti
communiste français a critiqué d'une
façon très claire et c'est l'esprit du
22e congrès le stalinisme et terrestres
seulement reste la pratique et il est
tout à fait compréhensible normal que
dans la pratique subsiste encore des
éléments de stalinisme d'abord parce que
les règles de fonctionnement du parti
communiste en france date de la période
stalinienne et que par conséquent dans
la mesure où ces règles n'ont pas toutes
été abrogée il y à des entraves qui
empêchent le parti communiste français
d'avoir complètement éliminé les
séquelles du stalinisme qui pèsent sur
lui
on parle du stalinisme comme c'était une
sorte d'accident de l'histoire est ce
que ça n'ait pas davantage quand même
coûté
il s'agit de savoir le sens que l'on
donne aux mots accident si c'est un
accident au sens d'une simple péripétie
naturellement pas le problème c'est que
le socialisme au lieu de se développer
dans les grands pays industrialisés de
l'occident s'est développée d'abord dans
des pays qui était relativement sous
développés économiquement et
culturellement à l'exception de
tchécoslovaquie
mais on sait qu'une influence soviétique
qui a été déterminante et par conséquent
il n'a pas pu revêtir un certain nombre
de traits fondamentaux sans lequel le
socialisme ne peut exister vraiment et
en premier lieu la démocratie politique
la démocratie politique existe t-elle au
sein du parti communiste ou plus
exactement la discussion qui s'est
engagé difficilement ces temps ci
jusqu'où peut-elle aller bien c'est
justement un des problèmes que pose la
vie actuelle du parti communiste
français
son 22e congrès a été une avancée tout à
fait décisive historique
c'est pourquoi personnellement je vais
tendance à la comparer au congrès tours
de 1920 qui avait donné naissance au
parti communiste
mais bien entendu et pour les raisons
que je rappelais tout à l'heure il reste
encore des résistances à surmonter des
structures à dépasser si l'on veut aller
plus avant sur la voie d'un
fonctionnement plus démocratique du
centralisme démocratique à l'intérieur
du parti communiste et les prises de
position les quelques prises de position
d'intellectuels comme co ces temps ci
seront elles suffisantes pour arriver à
ce changement
écoutez les prises de position de ces
intellectuels dont vous parliez ne sont
que la partie visible de l'iceberg
en réalité le parti communiste français
à travers ses vingt-six mille cellules
est animé d'un débat très profond très
vaste qui ne fonctionne pas encore d'une
façon totalement satisfaisante en raison
de la pratique historique dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure qui fait par
exemple personnellement je n'ai pas pu
publier d'articles dans l'humanité ou de
france nouvelle qu'on aurait souhaité
mais fondamentalement il y à un débat
démocratique qui se développe et qui
concerne et les 620 milles près quand
verra-t-on emboutir côté cela c'est un
autre problème d'une part ce n'est pas
moi à prendre des décisions car je n'ai
pas de responsabilité
à l'intérieur le parti communiste
français le comité central de ce parti
se réunit mercredi et jeudi et c'est lui
qui doit prendre des décisions
d'autre part je ne crois pas que l'on
puisse espérer avoir des changements
trop rapides
je pense que simplement le débat doit se
poursuivre qu'il doit permettre aux
communistes de donner leur opinion est
qu'il doit par conséquent à aboutir à
des transformations probablement du type
de celle que connaît le parti communiste
espagnol à son 23e congrès et s'il n'ya
pas de changement avant longtemps
resterez-vous au sein du parti
communiste et ça c'est une question je
ne me pose pas parce que je suis tout à
fait convaincu que ces changements
auront lieu il me semble qu'il faut
simplement faire en sorte que les
communistes assument leur charge leur
destin qu'ils puissent définir
maintenant leur nouvelle identité est
appliquée d'une façon unitaire est
résolu leur nouvelle politique
l'humanité sans nommer personne vous
accusent d' alimenter la campagne anti
communiste je n'ai pas du tout ce
sentiment je pense au contraire que ce
qui alimente la campagne anticommuniste
sont ceux qui conservent des pratiques
qui sont héritées du passé comme par
exemple le fait de mettre au pilon une
brochure sous le prétexte qu'elle
comprendrait une image représentant un
dirigeant du parti communiste serrant la
main de leonid putsch au cours d'un
meeting à la mutualité et
si je parle à la radio ou à la télé si
j'écris dans un certain nombre de
journaux comme par exemple dans le monde
et bien c'est parce que je crois qu'il
est nécessaire de s'adresser à un public
assez large pour lui faire comprendre la
nature des problèmes posés et me
semble-t-il
ce n'est pas ni une seconde nature ni
une façon d'abuser de la situation ni un
plaisir que je me donne mais tout
simplement une nécessité de notre temps
et il me semble que ce qui est important
ce n'est pas tant le lieu d'où l'on
parle que la nature des problèmes posés
et il faudra bien que ces problèmes
soient résolus
parce que c'est dans la solution de ces
problèmes que réside non seulement
l'avancé du parti communiste français
mais l'avancé de toute la gauche pour
qu'elle devienne majorité en france
voilà un dossier qui restera encore
longtemps ouvert semble-t-il
voilà surtout pour la politique ce soir
les passagers du boeing sud-coréen qui a
fait un atterrissage forcé en urss jeudi
soir ont quitté helsinki c'est à dire la
finlande
aujourd'hui trois d'entre eux seulement
deux français et un allemand de l'ouest
ont renoncé à poursuivre leur voyage
vers séoul
ils regagneront leur pays dans la soirée
nous les attendons et vous pourrez
vraisemblement entendre les premiers
témoignages sur cette affaire dans notre
dernière édition
peu après 22h30 les autres passagers eux
ont repris place dans un boeing des
lignes aériennes coréenne et vols en ce
moment même vers séoul quant à l'avion
il est toujours bloquée sur un lac gelé
non loin de mourmansk la compagnie
aérienne coréenne qui en est
propriétaire estimerait qu'il est un peu
trop abîmée pour tenter de le récupérer
pour terminer ce journal je vous propose
de repartir vers l'italie mais cette
fois il s'agira de cinéma mercredi un
film la sphère maury va sortir sur les
écrans français un film qui évoque une
affaire mal connue de l'italie des
années 1920 césar et maurice est un
préfet de police que mussolini envoie en
sicile pour y pourchasser la mafia maury
l'incorruptible c'était l'homme de la
situation mais jusqu'au pouvait-il aller
c'est ce que ce film me pose comme
question dans le montage que nous vous
proposons ce soir et que georges big
nous propose des extraits de ce film est
aussi les réflexions du metteur en scène
pasquale squitieri et de claudia
cardinale
à l'heure où l'italie bitat drame
qui secoue la population toute entière
la fermera à niort capétiens je sais que
tu es chez toi tu as signé le massacre
de la famille facile au riz c'est
aujourd'hui que nous allons régler nos
comptes une fois pour toutes
j'aurais mieux fait de rester à palerme
fautrè dans ton fauteuil à donner des
ordres
bref c'est inutile dé faire du cinéma de
toiles y tient on comprend pas les
racines et c'est de cette actualité et
en italie il ya beaucoup d une formation
d historique sociologique et cetera qui
sont oubliés avec la volonté précise et
de l'oublier
on peut pas oublier que la mafia lexis
tu connais engagement avec le grand bain
de sang de sa première sortie dans la
vie du pays et il faut pas oublier ça
pour comprendre comment cette
organisation qui partait d'une exigence
dessiné par une unité de bien
aujourd'hui c'est bien plus qu'une
mauvaise session criminelle mais c'est
une situation politique devait
absolument récusé la sentence
d'acquittement que vous venez de
prononcer je ne veux pas que l'autorité
pénitentiaire les libère je ne peux pas
je ne peux pas prendre le risque de
demander une réouverture du dossier qui
re déboucherait sur un non lieu ce
serait la fin de ma carrière de
magistrat je peux m'employer à vous
faire avoir une promotion et une
mutation
non je ne demande pas de privilèges la
vérité est que vous avez peur mais de
qui
comprenez donc pas que vous êtes les
premières victimes de votre silence
je suis né pour combattre ce qui vous
exploite ce qui vous à vannes et ceux
qui vont vous massacrer par moments on
croirait que vous êtes de leur côté
sommes pas de leur côté
mais pas non plus du vôtre la plaie de
la sicile c'est la misère et tant qu'il
y aura la misère des choses ne pourront
pas changer c'est ce qu'elle veut dire
c'est pour ça qu'elle tient tête
c'est une c'est le personnage qui
représente à l'aserc la science la
sicile pascal a voulu faire justement
est-ce de symboles de la sicile ne
paraît pas pris vous avez massacré pour
m'intimider piémontais je ne voudrais
jamais les siciliens au kurier en chine
mais c'est d'ailleurs les plus gros
succès italien de cette année ici
surpris vous sait trop ce que le succès
d'un film on commande historique l'un
qui propose des aigles oppose oui la
situation d'un homme d'ordre
ça veut dire qu'ils en effet beaucoup de
gens beaucoup d'italiens aujourd'hui ils
ont besoin d'avoir des points de vue de
référence auxquelles ces entités
vous ne pouvez pas traiter les femmes et
les enfants comme de vulgaires bandits
personne ne comprendrait cette attitude
et l'état n'en sortirait pas reconduit
mais enfin pas qui croyez vous parlez ce
panneau c'est une guerre que nous
faisons et non une procession à la
vierge mario
maintenant on a laissé femme est belle
non
on nous répond
oh
pas favoris sur les écrans français à
partir de mercredi
il y avait un tiercé aujourd'hui à
longchamp dans le prix des épinettes
pour l'emporter il fallait jouer le 11
le 13 et le 16
robert chapatte nous le disait il ya
quelques minutes le 11 ces dandys boy le
13 6 rabat et le cese pirro joc les
rapports pour 5 francs dans l'ordre oui
les lire en même temps que moi 11700 5
francs pour 5 francs dans le bon ordre
et dans un ordre différent 2341 france
le pmu annonce d'ailleurs que 3115
personnes ont joué aujourd'hui cette
bonne combinaison
la météo pour demain le temps sera peu
nuageux sauf de la bretagne aux pyrénées
où le ciel se couvrira avec quelques
averses et des orages épars
cette aggravation s'étendra ensuite
hélas aux autres régions il fera
toutefois toujours très beau dans le
nord et le nord-est de la france
voilà cette édition est maintenant
terminé notre prochain journal aux
alentours ou plutôt très précisément à
22h37 en compagnie de pierre alain je
vous souhaite de passer une bonne soirée
à